[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de page
spéciale numérique nous allons essayer
de comprendre le monde vers lequel nous
allons avec des mots dont on qu'on
entend et qu'on ne comprend pas toujours
je parle pas aux cons crypto moneo nft
au métavers ce monde qui avait trop de
notre de demain mais aussi à
l'importance du numérique du digital dès
aujourd'hui dans nos vies privées pour
les sociétés pour les entreprises et
pour parler de tout ça virgin flv
bonjour bonjour vous êtes la fondatrice
de star ac star ac avec 1 h 1 stacom
hackers ces attaques
et qui est une société de formation du
système de formation continue on en
parle tout à l'heure avec avec vous et
avec nous alors en visio maylis bulk
bonjour
vous êtes spécialiste de e-business vous
êtes co auteur avec
virginie de d'un livre de qui s'appelle
stratégie et marketing qui va sortir
dans quelques semaines la nouvelle
édition sort dans quelle que soit trois
semaines trois semaines voilà et vous
avez vous allez lancer dans quelques
semaines aussi un dea nft alors vous
allez nous expliquer pourquoi et comment
et comment ça marche et puis avec
d'aussi valérie damilleville bonjour
bonjour vous êtes professeur dans une
école cheval miley cyrus cool on va
expliquer ce que c'est dans quelques
instants mais digital cloud et amanda
calixte bonjour vous êtes aussi à my
digital school et vous êtes le
responsable du développement commercial
de cette école et puis nous avons
beaucoup d'étudiants qui sont voilà qui
assistent à cette émission qui sont des
étudiants de ma visite halte school on
va peut-être commencer par cette école
nous vous nous expliquer ce que cesse
une école du numérique au fond tout à
fait donc mais digital school a pour
ambition de former et d'accompagner des
étudiants post bac au bac + 5 à travers
différentes formations pour leur
permettre de s'orienter dans le domaine
du numérique donc ça peut être des
formations en marketing digital en date
un marketing en développement foule
stack à travers des cursus en stage ou
en alternance d'accord et il ya des
écoles allez y en a un peu partout en
france effectivement donc mais digital
school est présent à travers la france
et compte aujourd'hui 18 campus digi
campus dont un ici même effectivement
même à montigny le bretonneux a monté de
brotonne absolument
combien d'étudiants à peu près au
minimum 200 étudiants d'accord vous
confronter avec des formations
différentes d'un argument de 3 5 ans
enfin exactement donc là la volonté
vraiment cd accompagné tout au long de
leur parcours de formation donc des
formations en cinq ans d'accord c'est
plutôt
déduire piaule bac scientifique alors
c'est une formation enfin sans profilage
ni prévost qui c'est à dire que les
étudiants peuvent vraiment rejoindre
notre école à travers des tests
d'admission mêlée en tout cas les tests
se sont ouverts à toutes et à tous donc
qu'il soit issu d'un cursus scientifique
littéraire
donc c'est ouvert
merci des cv alors startac donc c'était
une c'est une entreprise de formation
continue ou digitale numérique 1
l'avez vous l'avez créé il ya combien de
temps c'est assez récent on a créé en
fait c'est un centre de formation
continue qui forme à des la montée en
compétences sur des sujets bien précis
donc le format c'est très intensif c'est
en forme à 1 3 jours donc l'idée c'est
vraiment d'apprendre par la pratique
donc il ya 90 % finalement de pratique
dans nos formations et donc et donc
c'est assez inclusif puisque c'est
accessible en fait c'est tout salarié
soit en reconversion soit en poste qui
veut monter en compétences ou des chefs
d'entreprise qui est noir qui veulent
s'informer sur des sujets bien précis du
marketing digital et la formation c'est
sûr qu'elle dans quels domaines on en
adsl qui marche très bien c'est
apprendre à prospecter via linkedin
vraiment ça attire beaucoup de
dirigeants beaucoup de commerciaux et
voilà comment savoir se servir des
réseaux sociaux vont imposer avec une
dimension toujours demande lounguine
voilà est on est on est pas très on
n'est pas uniquement orientée outil on
est aussi orienté stratégie donc c'est
transmettre les bonnes questions à se
poser c'est vraiment une approche de
réflexion ne prend que des intervenants
qui sont opérationnels en activité avec
un bon track-record forcément et donc on
espère que les cordes dans ses défauts
le traduire ils ont un bon un bon
parcours et justifient d'une belle
réussite d'accord c'est important pour
nous d'avoir des pointures en termes
intervenants et peut-être un mot avec
avec maelys aussi sur sur le livre qui
est donc stratégie marketing
alors le livre je les jets rédigé la
première édition à l'époque entre la
couverture du prochain en 2013 pour la
petite histoire la petite anecdote
moi je me suis formé en autodidacte
et marketing et en fait j'ai appris avec
micro ap et donc quand ils sont venus
voir pour me proposer de rédiger
finalement un livre pour apprendre en
fiches pratiques très opérationnelle
j'ai accepté rendre un peu la suite et
donc j'ai c'est la quatrième édition
cette fois avec maelys qui est toujours
sur le même format les bonnes questions
à se poser des cas pratiques illustrées
tout et en images c'est pour apprendre
vraiment les fondamentaux du marketing
au bercail et devis du e-marketing
e-marketing et maëlys où les riders mot
sur ce livre oui bah j'ai été ravie
quand virginie m'a proposé de collaborer
avec elle pour l'écrire et pour la
deuxième année que cette fois ci on
était ensemble au vote selvez de las
vegas ont été baignés par toutes les
nouvelles technologies et toutes les
nouveautés sur le secteur qui arrivent
et du coup on m'a proposé d'écrire avec
elle dans ce livre j'ai dit tout de
suite oui ce que transmettent c'est
vraiment hyper important aujourd'hui est
fait en sorte que tout le monde
comprenne tous les enjeux tu lui marqué
très bien alors on va aborder dans
quelques instants ben c'est toutes ces
notions nouvelles le métavers les nefs
télé les crypto baudet mais avant on va
s'interroger sur ce qu'est ce monde qui
est déjà de monde d'aujourd'hui qu'est
le monde numérique où le monde dit
digital
[Musique]
alors
pour faire simple d'abord qu'est-ce que
c'est le numérique et vous qu'est ce que
c'est le digital
c'est très vert c'est très bête digital
lüthi talent est partout c'est le web
c'est internet
c'est
sociaux et ce également tous les outils
qui nous entoure et qu'on utilise dont
on ne peut plus passer qui sont aux
ordinateurs nos smartphones les objets
connectés
et dans l'enseignement par exemple c'est
très sympa alors vous êtes des vidéos de
brain et digital school qui était
consacré à ça mais c'est très important
ça change aussi la manière d'enseigner
ça change la manière d'enseigner à nous
ça nous oblige à quitter notre zone de
confort et à utiliser
des outils et surtout à
revenir sur des fondamentaux qui sont
les fondamentaux stratégiques
auprès d'étudiants qui ont pas forcément
qu'ils sont très utilisateurs d'outils
mais qui n'ont pas forcément la
connaissance du fonctionnement de ces
outils et de là est la finalité de
digital vérité vais justement bas vous
parliez ddd des chefs d'entreprise des
salariés qu'ils viennent se former c'est
vous qu'est-ce qui est ce qu'ils
viennent chercher au fond déjà allé sur
le digital en fait on a tous
l'impression de maîtriser tous les
outils certains se disent d'ailleurs à
une époque on entendait j'ai un compte
facebook c'est bon je peux être
community manager bon et quand même un
pas à passer notamment dans la réflexion
stratégique et donc ce qu'ils viennent
chercher c'est aussi comprendre comment
on peut faire des choses de façon
efficace donc ça commence par se poser
les bonnes questions identifiées le bon
problème on pourrait utiliser leur
adresser les bonnes cibles et ensuite le
bon message et utiliser les bons leviers
et suivre les bonnes qu'à piller les
bons paramètres de performance
voilà en tout cas l'idée c'est toujours
suivre les performances et c'est ce
qu'on peut faire sur le numérique donc
c'est plutôt plutôt intéressant et donc
je pense qu'il faut vraiment intégré
cette stratégie très en amont pour
pouvoir me faire des choses qui
fonctionnent boudeuse pour ce faire un
vos communautés manager
il ya maintenant presque toutes les
autres prisons des community managers
dont un est le métier se transforme
sterk en fait au départ c'était
simplement animer des communautés et
aujourd'hui il faut apprendre à créer du
contenu et si la première interface
client sert qu'aujourd'hui vous avez un
problème avec votre opérateur
téléphonique est ce que vous faites vous
aller déverser votre haine sur les
réseaux sociaux est donc un community
manager il fait pas seulement de la
publication de contenus basique il va
jusqu'à répondre s'est il fait les
services at on appris les formes et elle
le nouveau service après vente sav c'est
vraiment du comité de nature presque
ouais un mandat calix donc le tout à
fait effectivement et c'est important
pour les entrepries je pense de suivre
rapidement
l'avancé du digital pour ne pas être
obsolète et pouvoir répondre à la
demande du marché et ça passe va
justement par des formations et par la
formation aussi des équipes c'est pour
cela que ma dgta school accompagne aussi
les entreprises en leur proposant des
profils a formé et qui pourront par la
suite garder au sein de leur équipe les
fidéliser et les faire évoluer ses
gammes une filière pardon communauté
manager par exemple vous effectivement
donc la formation et marketing social
media & business permet aux étudiants de
se former au métier de community manager
d'accord
les initiés vous dites d'ailleurs c'est
vrai il ya aussi une évolution de
consommateurs il est plus il est plus
comme il était à voir et les plus chers
et les plus statique il est plus
attendons juste l'information et puis
alors acheté il faut et il a changé j'y
vais même contradictoires parfois il est
surprenant
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
déjà la relation entre la marque et
l'utilisateur et le client a changé en
fait on attend plus d'une marque qu'elle
soit uniquement rassurante le gros
building les gros logo m6 qui bougeait
en 3d on attend aujourd'hui une relation
plus humaine et ce qui veut dire humaine
ça implique des émotions ça implique de
la confiance c'est un utilisateur qui
est plus exigeant parce que finalement
il est mieux informé en tout cas il a
l'impression d'être envoyés maintenant
des gens qui regardent sur doctissimo
une question et qui arrive chez le
médecin dont je sais ce que je sais que
j'ai finalement donc on a des
utilisateurs même la formation du
médecin exact
il les évalue et en dévoile une option
groupe renault ibr aujourd'hui même si
le client les à l'évaluation c'est en
effet tout le monde s'est valu
aujourd'hui a dans le monde on essaie
vraies
qualités de confiance finalement est-ce
que les est ce que les étudiants de
medical school évalue les les profs vous
fuit
nous mettons en place des suivi qualité
qui permettent aux étudiants
régulièrement d'apporter des
améliorations ou d'exprimer leur
satisfaction sur les méthodes
d'enseignement au sein du corps
enseignant effectivement donc ce
consommateur et les mieux informés il
est mieux informé il est plus exigeant
il a ils apprécient qu'on le sollicite
et pour la co création il aime ça aussi
qu'on prenne son avis en compte à la
fois très sensible à l'éthique de plus
en plus
tout à l'heure j'ai ça aussi un et c'est
vrai que je disais contradictoire c'est
parfois un peu comme ça peut être
parfois un peu contradictoire mais c'est
en tout cas c'est une exigence on a
tellement aussi matraquer le sujet le
made in france oui y'a quand même des
sujets qui sont récurrents et donc il
est face habilité tout ça c'est
important et puis un des points qui est
aussi très important c'est qui quand ils
consomment ils s'expriment et donc quand
vous posez un téléphone un iphone sur la
table vous posez pas un dock à 32 10
vous vous exprimez des valeurs exprimé
de rejoindre une entreprise avec ce qui
est associé vous accepté de rentrer dans
une communauté et donc ce consommateur
là il veut rentrer dans des valeurs
éthiques qui veut rentrer dans des
valeurs humaines on dit souvent que le
porteur même d'un projet d'une start up
aujourd'hui par son storytelling en même
finalement ses utilisateurs à s'exprimer
à être parfois clivant sur des sujets et
c'est important de d'emmener les gens
dans une belle histoire donc donc il
faut raconter une histoire c'est
important parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'on est dans un monde un peu on repart
à des nouvelles notions dans quelques
instants mais on ait l'impression
parfois qu'on est dans un monde un peu
virtuel un peu autres or vous nous dites
tout à fait le contraire au fond c'est
presque c'est résume à ce que le le
récit que vous nous faites il faut
raconter des histoires c'est le vrai
challenge d'aujourd'hui c'est arrivé à
raconter une belle histoire retranscrire
des émotions à travers le web donc
derrière l'écran est à la fois
finalement de prouver qu'il y avait un
vrai problème à la base et que la
personne est concerné quand vous avez la
marque respire je pas si vous voyez des
nouvelles marques cosmétiques quand la
personne s'exprimant en voilà j'ai
failli avoir un cancer et donc j'ai créé
une marque qui évite d'avoir un cancer
quand vous avez
meetic déjà à l'époque exprimé qu'ils
étaient dans un repas avec des gens qui
était célibataire et donc les idées
naissent finalement de vraies histoires
et donc faut arriver à bien les
retranscrire et surtout bien les
communiquer pour que les gens s'engagent
et finalement rejoignant homogène cette
belle histoire
oui les utilisateurs ou les clients
attendent autre chose des marques que de
la publicité est un produit qu'on leur
voix là où un service qu'on leur apporte
prémâché comme ça ils attendent
effectivement qu'on nous raconte une
histoire il faut qu'ils attendent
d'authenticité bio la part des marques
et le digital le permet notamment des
finales
et accents de ce monde et les
utilisateurs sont extrêmement exigeants
et moins 10 par an souvent mes étudiants
que les premiers influenceurs c'est pas
les stars qu'on voit sur les réseaux
sociaux les premiers influenceurs
démarque c'est leurs propres clients
dans leur propre pays utilisateurs et
donc nous sommes tous influenceurs nous
sont tous en capacité de créer du
contenu de créer du du mauvais et du bad
buzz et
d'influencé sur le contenu et le
parcours des marques c'est plutôt
intéressant
mais ben ali se veulent que voulait
interdire c'est ce sujet
baala pour l'instant où je vous écoute
je suis d'accord avec instruments dans
tout ce que vous vite et il ya des
points encore effectivement à creuser
sur une sur deux parcours d'achat sur le
client sur le type aujourd'hui pour
évoluer en permanence et il faut prendre
en compte un autre aspect aussi dont on
n'a pas encore tout à fait parler quand
on disait les réseaux sociaux donc faut
penser vraiment à faire de la veille
tout le temps parce que ça évolue
tellement vite aujourd'hui et les
algorithmes donc les fameuses
algorithmes qui régissent les réseaux
peuvent être mis à jour par toi fois
dans le mois donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut aussi être extrêmement réactif pour
pouvoir proposer à nos consommateurs du
contenu qui correspond à ses attentes
mais qui va aussi être mis en avant par
l'algorithme puisqu'on aura réussi à
faire quelque chose qui va correspondre
aux attentes du réseau sociaux autant
qu'elle
c'est vrai que c'est un million en
évolution constante 1 et comment on fait
alors justement quand on fait de la
formation
que ce soit pour le pour les entreprises
que ce soit pour les étudiants pour être
toujours au niveau 20 c'est vrai que ça
change
vahid on est en veille moi par exemple
je passe entre un quart d'heure la mine
20 minutes le matin et le soir sur
twitter et linkedin a fermé la veille
sur ce qui se passe dans l'univers du
digital donc je suis dépendant des
tendances et influenceurs c'est comme ça
que je suis tombé là sur la révolution
mais l'averse il ya quelques et quelques
journées que avec rob knox on en parlera
tout à l'heure
et donc c'est une obligation coton de
canton en canton et dans cet univers
mais savoir qu'on a une fois pour toutes
enfin on n'allait pas permanente mais en
veille permanente six essais on pas
faire ce métier sans envahir c'est
important c'est vrai que l'on met un
point d'honneur à me prendre des gens
qui sont uniquement en activité parce
qu'on peut très vite être largué dans ce
domaine et c'est vrai que je moi je
crois pas être formateur à 100% du temps
je pense qu'en fait si on n'a pas une
activité terrain derrière qui permet de
pratiquer pouvoir tester en permanence
et transmettre cette expérience c'est
moins efficace en tout cas donc pour moi
c'est un des points essentiels
il ya des âges où c'est fini
je crois pas mon père ly mon livre donc
j'imagine tout va bien maintenant je
pense que à n'importe quel âge on peut
encore se former évolué en savoir plus
après c'est une question de volonté de
chacun mais parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui disent je suis ça y est je suis
paumé un on entend ça non
et puis le marketing digital c'est pas
du développement on est quand même parce
que c'est quand même relativement plus
accessible c'est un mix de psychologie 2
c'est pas une c'est pas une science
exacte c'est pas du calcul on est quand
même sur voilà exactement il faut sentir
aussi à partir mais on connaît bien sa
cible et on comprend comment la dresser
après voilà et on convient que ça avec
un bon usage des outils ça fonctionne
bien je reviens sur ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure quand vous aidiez
raconter une histoire ou dit aussi
l'expérience est aussi importante que le
produit oui le parcours utilisateur est
très important on dit aussi que et
aujourd'hui on le ressent regardez bien
comment ça évolue d'un point de vue même
marketing global le papier cadeau compte
autant que le cadeau il est
effectivement quand vous arrivez dans
une boutique apple et que la boutique
est hyper épurer les vendeurs sont hyper
moderne hyper sympa est arrivé qu'une
tablette on n'attend pas on est servi et
c'est ça joue beaucoup et c'est pareil
sur le pari sur le web quand vous
arrivez sur un site quand le parcours
est simplifié intuitif simple que
finalement vous avez une commande en
deux clics vous êtes informés en
permanence on avait rien à faire sajoo
physiquement dans la relation à la
marque et c'est hyper essentielle et
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire c'est à
dire que coucher parcours client ça
permet de savoir à quel moment il faut
pouvoir l'adresser au niveau niveau
digital qu'est-ce qui doit recevoir quel
message etc pour l'accompagner et faire
une boucle puisque l'enjeu c'est aussi
de le fidéliser et est-ce que
l'esthétique de ce monde-là du monde
digital deux mondes numériques c'est un
monde un peu
pas trop encombrée par les choses quoi
vous parlez de ses magasins apple par
exemple on voit bien c'est assez assez
assez nues je dirais presque c'est ça
une esthétique aux fondus du monde du
monde numérique pas forcément parce
qu'on se rend compte aussi certains
tests ont été faits sur des boutiques
comme cdiscount tout dépend de la proche
qu'on a quand vous arrivez sur cdiscount
vous fait pas mal elle avait quelque
chose exactement là on dans la brocante
à la foir'fouille et donc on aime
on aime chercher parce qu'on est content
d'avoir trouvé l'offre est en ce sens
unique et très content de l'avoir
trouvée alors que dans d'autres univers
on se sent plutôt bien quand c'est épuré
parce que ce sont des beaux produits
très bien rangé très très haut de gamme
donc on s'identifiait 6 à 5 ans quelles
sont les demandes de vos étudiants
elles sortent elles sont variées d'abord
déformée mais oui demain sur les outils
soient une nouvelle technologie ouais
voilà ils sont ils sont très ou type qui
sont très utilisateurs des outils et
donc nous entre autres à nos objectifs
c'est de les ramener aux fondamentaux
virginie parle effectivement la cible
fatouri fondamentaux du marketing qui
finalement parliez de génération existe
depuis 30 ans les fondamentaux du
marketing en fait des outils ont changé
mais la cible est là le sauver
l'événement est la leur les fondamentaux
sont toujours là donc c'est les ramener
aux fondamentaux et puis les ramener
aussi aux utilisateurs savoir que qui
utilisent des outils
voilà savoir
qu'ils étaient alors on va on va passer
deuxième partie pour essayer de définir
un certain nombre de mots qu'on entend
beaucoup sur lesquels moi je ne
comprends pas grand chose je le dit
suite donc très très didactique mais je
crois que c'est le cas de beaucoup de
gens qui peuvent nous regardent et qui
entendent ces mots qui savent pas
exactement à quoi ça correspond voilà
les sept partis dit c'est quoi alors
[Musique]
alors on va parler des élèves t as monde
à calixte qu'est ce que c'est donc ces
jeunes fans du bbl token ses jetons nos
fonds gibles ça veut dire quoi domfront
j blidge
fongible c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas
aller changer contre quelque chose
d'équivalent par exemple une pièce de
monnaie va être fongible si on prend
deux pièces d'un euro elles vont être
différentes mais bon avant la même
équivalentes d'accord
exactement on peut on peut les échanger
alors que les nefs t vont permettre de
gâcher cette valeur à travers un code
sécurisé qui passe à travers la blocs
chaîne donc juste pousser quoi le bloc
v6 et laboeuf chaîne donc c'est un
système informatif et participatif qui
va permettre justement de sécuriser une
transaction est donc nft sont une
tendance qui qui a vu le jour justement
c'est une tendance qui a vu le jour à
partir des années à 2010 mais c'est
justement tout à fait mais qui s'est
vraiment développée à travers la mise en
ligne d'un jeu vidéo qui reprend un peu
le contexte le oui le contexte des
tamagotchi mais 3.0 qui s'appelle crypto
qui tease justement et c'est ce qui a
permis de vraiment populariser et de
lancer une nouvelle dynamique
nft d'accord alors on a vu il ya eu par
exemple une oeuvre d'art qui s'est
acheté plusieurs millions de dollars
qui seront ses vues que bleu le rappeur
booba avait vendu une partie en tout cas
de son prochain clip et qu'il a empoché
très vite tout dit ou six cent mille
euros ce qui est ce qui est quand même
énorme c'est ça effectivement a donc si
bien qu aujourd'hui la voilà le vol
voile alors qu'ils se conduisent à
l'oeuvre d'art qui s'est vendu si je ne
me trompe pas à plus de 69 millions de
dollars donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
les nst sont utilisés par par toute la
population à hyères - un bond de la
population pour vendre différentes
choses qu'ils peuvent
être utilisé dans des secteurs
d'activités comme la musique l'art ou
encore le design alors sur un cétacé un
peu particulier parce que général quand
on achète une oeuvre d'art au laos et
pour la montre et ce pour l'exposer là
les sept oeuvres d'art là qu'on voit on
peut la voir quoi sur une tablette ou
sur son smartphone non ça c'est ça
uniquement de façon virtuelle quoi
penser sa virtuelle puisque en réalité n
existe pas donc c'est vraiment
uniquement de façon virtuelle on peut
aussi acheter des chaussures virtuel
qu'est une célèbre marque qui a dénoncé
sa et donc on peut acheter la paire de
chaussures et l'avoir virtuellement on
peut également acheter des meubles
virtuel et tout ça à travers le système
de la belote est d'aider les personnes
âgées comme moi on est mais à quoi ça
sert c'était bien sûr dire que
c'est vrai que ça permet
de vivre aussi dans dans une dans une
nouvelle ère et de pouvoir
développer ses talents et par le biais
du digital de pouvoir les vendre
sur différentes plateformes qui sont qui
sont aussi mises en place à cet effet et
de vendre des oeuvres d'art sans passer
par les
[Musique]
circuits c'est ça les circuits
classiques
on dit aussi ce qui fait que l'inde une
des raisons du succès de cftc qui a
beaucoup d'argent qui circule 1 et puis
ça rejoint aussi le nouveau consommateur
qui critiquait beaucoup d'ego qui a
beaucoup de seins produit donc c'est
fini pour lui tout seul rien côté
égoïste up gabon non bah quand le tweet
du fondateur de twitter seraient 2 5
millions
c'est le dollar et existence et sa voix
et se dire je lai enfin on parle
vraiment des goûts enfin aussi donc ça
joue aussi sur l'évolution des
comportements en ligne est ce qu'on peut
voir qui nous paraît parfois
irrationnelle m'enfin oui parce que 2
millions 50 canton mais je sais pas où
soit plus de 60 millions sur neuf rabat
jeudi je dis pas que c'est pas parce
qu'on a envie de cette chose et on a
assisté l'approprier mais on peut penser
aussi à la revendre peut-être parfois et
on sait pas le tweet à 2 millions il a
des choses de monter ses distances assez
sympa il pourrait céder paris
effectivement après est-ce que ça
spécule ou pas derrière sur ça c'est
effectivement il ya aussi les joueurs de
la nba qui ont mis en ligne des vidéos
justement de certains matchs et qui se
vendent aussi très cher donc c'est ça
permet de toucher un peu toute la
population et permettre à la population
de s'exprimer en fonction aussi de 2 c
de ses appétences à travers
tous les secteurs d'activité la musique
maïlys buzz que
vous allez lancer vous une collection de
nft dans quelques semaines alors on a on
a compris ce que c'était à peu près les
neft et en quoi consiste votre
collection et qui quel public vous
essayer de toucher
alors nous la collection qui va
s'appeler le gong artem club c'est un
hommage aux artistes qui ont marqué
l'histoire depuis toujours donc on a
sélectionné 25 artistes auxquels on a
mis des très bons en particulier et
après on a rajouté aussi touche
personnelle donc des fonds différents
des éléments différenciants des couleurs
de peau particulière par exemple marbré
obsidienne ruby tchad etc qui vont
déterminer la rareté des pièces de la
collection et dans les collections à
n'acheter en fait qui fait l'intérêt et
la spéculation derrière dont est
justement en train de parler c'est ce
degré de rareté donc par exemple sur une
collection qui a dix mille pièces vous
allez avoir le plus rare qui va être
placé un sur dix mille et mourad milles
sur 10 évidemment le un sur dix mille va
valoir beaucoup plus cher que le deal
soit 2000 et pour ça on utilise des
outils comme rarities point de soultz
qui va nous donner directement le degré
de rareté des pièces de la collection on
a aussi d'autres outils comme ça ici
tools qui lui nous donne le trading au
niveau des collections par exemple les
achats qui ont été réalisés sur les
dernières 24 heures le dernier jour où
les deux derniers jours pour nous
d'avoir un petit peu des tendances de
marché et c'est une collection va
marcher le mieux qu'une autre ou pas
dans le cas de la nôtre elle sort donc
dans quelques semaines donc là on est en
pleine communication dessus et les
outils de communication principaux sur
l'a9 toys avec discorde twitter
télégramme ci est quasiment tout se
passe donc sur ces réseaux la la
communauté on essaie de la fédérer et
qu'elles échangent donc d'augmenter le
degré de désirabilité de la collection
et après on la minute donc on la met à
disposition sur le site internet chacun
achète au prix qui a été définie on ne
sait pas à l'avancé
lequel ils achètent donc dans un premier
temps on va pas dire par exemple
j'achète la plus rare tout de suite on
achète au hasard minutes donc on va
prendre un des éléments de la collection
et il ya un rêve il donc on va révéler
quel élément n'a dans les heures ou dans
les 48 heures qui arrivent et c'est à ce
moment là qu'on arrive sur marché
secondaire là qui est plus effectivement
la spéculation pour arriver à obtenir
la carte où l'élément le plus enfants
donc il ya un élément de risque ou de
jeu kouao faut
tordre à sa demande je viens sur mon
coeur oui on peut ainsi plusieurs alors
il ya certaines collections
par exemple à 2 min par personne donc
deux achats par personne et d'autres qui
vont remonter un peu plus donc on va
pouvoir en acheter jusqu'à 10 ou 20 par
personne
mais pour bien comprendre pas quand vous
dites dans votre collection d'artistes
mais ce que vous vendez sont pas d'aider
des oeuvres existantes enfin des erreurs
matérielles
alors on veut nous on a on s'est inspiré
des artistes après les artistes qui nous
plaisent et qui nous parle parce qu'ils
ont marqué le monde de l'histoire on les
a représentés avec non pas le 11/9 remet
des traits qui font penser à leurs
oeuvres ou des caractéristiques ils ont
chacun par exemple vont pas tous qu'il
s'est coupé l'oreille d'un coupé cl
oreilles dans la représentation et à
partir de là on a rajouté des traits et
donc c'est une collection hommage aux
artistes
d'accord la terreur vous allez investir
c'est votre cote
elle est en train de convaincre
ses tantes et c'est vrai que
ça m'a beaucoup surpris divx sa date de
2010 parce que c'est arrivé enfin on en
parle depuis quelques mois à peine
comment ça se fait que ça s'est mis
autant de temps à émerger
effectivement c'est je pense depuis la
l'expansion du jeu kiptoo qui tease et
puis aussi avec l'arrivée de la crypto
monnaie de la bonne chaîne qui favorise
aussi d'émergence je pensais dnf peut
penser que ça va un peu bouleversé le
monde de l'art il ya de gros débat là
dessus un certain qu'ils disent bah non
il n'y a pas de vrais artistes encore
qui s'exprime dans la nfc et aux voix en
même temps qu'il ya un marché qui est en
train de se créer
tout à fait des artistes qui s'expriment
déjà d'ipl dont parlait tout à l'heure
mais vous avez aussi des artistes comme
celle au dessus
aujourd'hui vous allez voir ce qu'il en
chine ont une connexion jr kicks et
qu'avant déjà énormément d'artistes déjà
connu et reconnu qui se lance aussi dans
la nef n'est est pas que des artistes
plastiques on va aussi avoir un côté
plus jikan on parlait tout à l'heure et
ça c'est un levier très important
à explorer pour les labels pour le
management extra de regarder comment
éventuellement monétiser avec les ch'tis
c'est vrai que
monde à calixte je pense que vous disiez
il ya ce blog chaîne qui fait qu' on est
on est sûrs dont on peut pas se faire
avoir je veux dire enfin quant aux
vestiaires pour doser d'investis voilà
tout à fait effectivement un hadoken
dans ma vraiment de sécuriser la
transaction à travers un code unique qui
va être délivrée lors lors de l'achat
c'est ce qui rend si unique
la pièce enfin l'élément qu'on va
acheter al'inverse de des jpeg avant
qu'ils étaient téléchargées en masse
qu'on pouvait échanger à tout va là ça
rend vraiment une pièce unique et tout
ce qui est rare et précieux donc ça je
pense que ça alimente aussi la
spéculation d'autant délecter maylis des
vieillards et alors il ya une communauté
qui est qui va ce qui est en train de se
créer il ya des enchères ou pas dans
l'est dans la nfc
oui bien sûr alors les hanches et là sur
le secondaire mais marquée sur le 2ème
marché la plateforme principale c'est
open ci et là vous pouvez aller voir sur
des collections qui fonctionne déjà très
bien comme bord d'un petit yacht club
qui représente des singes que vous
l'avez peut-être déjà vu en photo de
profil de certaines personnes
pour cette collection on peut par
exemple repéré à l est et qui nous plaît
et allez place yves d'enchères et après
les enchères vont pouvoir monter b c etc
mais oui c'est tout à fait un système
d'enchères et ça peut monter alors pour
ses collections de l' autre très cher et
ils ont des volumes de trade par exemple
200 mille neuf était donc vous savez que
depuis le début de la collection il ya
eu 200 milles et r 500 $ qui ont été
échangés juste sur cette collection
larmes alors il vous dit aussi vous avez
il faut faire attention aux frais et
eaux notamment les ce qu'on appelle le
gaz fissa les gaspille exactement alors
là dépend des blocs king sur lesquels
vous êtes inscrits par exemple en était
formellement interdit pour à l'intérieur
il ya des gars sfi qui sont très très
importants donc vous pouvez faire un an
à alain était allé en balade m 5 $ et
vous retrouvez avec 70 dollars d'aidé
suis à payer donc c'est à dire votre
achat par convenir à 75 sauf que votre
et les jeter lui il n'aura pas bougé de
ces cinq dollars initial donc un mois
qu'ils prennent énormément de valeur si
jamais vous d'essayer de le revendre
vous avez perdu ses gatti qui étaient
des frais de transaction mais par contre
si vous inscrire sur d'autres block
chaining comme polygone par exemple vous
allez avoir des gastrique ils vont être
très réduit donc ça ça dépend aussi dans
quoi est ce que vous voulez inscrire
votre collection
par contre attention il ya certains
obtiennent qui sont quand même plus à la
mode ou plus tendance que d'autres par
exemple certaines collections ne passe
jamais en dehors des terrains
puisque c'est celle qui rassurera tourne
aujourd'hui d'accord bon on va écouter
on essayait de comprendre un petit peu
plus ce qu'ils étaient s'énerve t on va
passer à un autre notre mot qu'on entend
beaucoup et c'est ok peut-être plus
connu c'est décrypte au menu
alors les décrypte abonnés qui va en
parler
non toujours pas
[Rires]
sujet de ma liste je crois que maylis
oui alors les crypto monnaie donc le
plus célèbre celle bitcoin je pense que
tous les ans tendu
exactement donc il ya quelques années
les premiers kwh investi c'était un vrai
de paris puisque ça va l'être 30
centimes le bitcoin aujourd'hui ces
personnes là ont fait fortune finalement
puisqu'on est atteint des sommets avec
un big twin qui soixante huit mille
dollars à peu près alors c'est les
crypto monnaies sont des monnaies qui
sont pas forcément encore reconnu dans
tous les états safetic ont commencé à
l'égalité
d'autres pas encore par exemple en
france qui dit qu elle n'est pas
reconnue comme une monnaie officielle
par contre vu l'engouement du tout tout
ce que ça a pris comme on pleure on va
pouvoir bientôt en tout cas certains
espèrent commencer à payer certaines
même chose en carte bleue avec une école
où par exemple des billets d'avion des
voyages etc il ya des pays qui accepte
il ya des pays qui on peut déjà acheter
des appartements
je sais qu speitel et au monténégro j'ai
lu des affiches voilà j'aurais pu
acheter un appartement de code par
exemple donc c'est des monnaies qui vont
avoir tendance à se démocratiser et
elles sont la base énormément sur la
confiance dans tout le monde est censé
pouvoir encore une fois tracé toutes les
transactions c'est vrai
je crois même qu un pays le salvador qui
vont faire sa monnaie
exactement c'est déjà fait depuis
quelques semaines ensemble ils l'ont
inscrite en monnaie nationale au même
titre que le petit fils également ce qui
fait peur justement peut-être aux gens
c'est justement que ce sont en principe
début n'est toujours pas reconnue par
les états comme comme comme les l'euro
comme les dollars enfin comme sur les
monnaies traditionnelles et mais qui
fait qu'est ce qui fait que
au fond c'est quoi ça veut dire qu'on
peut vous faut se passer on peut créer
une monnaie en se passant des états ça
veut dire ça le four décrypte au mode et
alors je ne suis pas une experte
partenaires à ce point là mais oui
effectivement c'est ça une monnaie qui a
été créée juste justement pour retirer
entraîné mais le pouvoir qu'ils étaient
donnés aux banques sur le contrôle donc
les premières personnes qui ont créé le
bitcoin c'est un petit peu ce que tard
en tête même si on sait toujours pas qui
l'a créé à l'heure actuelle et le reste
de la bloquer c'est effectivement pour
sécuriser les transactions les rendre
plus simple
après faut savoir que les états s'y
intéressent pas même de près notamment
les états unis qui investissent
massivement la chaîne la banque centrale
américaine a investi beaucoup dans le
bitcoin est tous les états regarde aussi
ils ont aussi décrété que notamment là
je pense que prendre des taxes sur
l'argent qui avait été fait sur les
spéculations étaient relativement
intéressant en france mais peu près 30%
c'est la taxe s'ils ont fait des gains
sur cette coupe domenech donc il ne la
reconnaissent pas en monnaie en tant que
tel mais d'un autre côté ça peut être
utile pour les taxes or on sait pas qui
a créé le bitcoin
n'ont toujours pas
toujours et alors bon le bitkom c'est
une mode est évidemment mondialement
mondialement connu mais si je veux par
exemple créer c'est pas la crim tobo des
de tv 78 je veux je peux le faire
oui ça sert à rien autant choquer mais
oui bah si vous pouvez après avoir fait
des gens investissent dessus que vous
ayez suffisamment liquidités pour faire
des échanges voilà un petit peu pensé
comme une vraie monnaie mais après whip
it cogne parce que ce n'est plus connu
mais il y en a des centaines
je pourrais vous situez intérêts après
très connu vous allez avoir c'était la
norme vous pouvez sur des plateformes
comme bind kraken colbert et c'est sur
lesquels vous allez retrouver le listing
de quasi toutes les crypto que qui sont
présentes sur ces quatre ans et on peut
investir ce qu'on veut 50 euros par
exemple un beau coup et même investir -
a commencé alors oui même seront sacrés
taux à 30 centimes en espérant que
bientôt ça vaille 1000 euros le coquen
par exemple et ça peut arriver ça ça
peut arriver
donc
suit aussi alors ça peut juste et aussi
à la wii c'est la bourse c'est un peu
comme la hausse aux spéculations oui sur
l'icône est ce que si on est très
volatile si on est patient est ce qu'on
a des chances de gagner un peu
ou pas où j'ai appelé s'effondrer
complètement je pense mais comme les
traders gagnent comme la boxe comme un
gant d'or c'est un métier comme un autre
nom mais à l'inter à long terme la
bourse a toujours faim généralement ça
on peut y perd encore des images je
crois qu'il ya 10 ou 15% de traders
convient vraiment un terme quand donc
après
je pense que fo spécialisé quoi mais y
aller comme un touriste moi c'est faire
attention quand même c'est au sol tout
en fait sur un terrain il ya plein de
bon business il ya bien il ya des
baisses d'opportunités il faut quand
même bien s'intéresser au sujet et au
risque qui a derrière quoi vous donc
dans les formations vous en parler de ça
oui on en parle oui et en curieusement
nos étudiants sont très intéressés par
par ses sujets comme ils sont intéressés
par les nouveaux outils ils sont aussi
intéressés par les nouvelles
technologies et sans cesse en fait
partie ils sont parfois utilisateur et
par mois utilisateurs un consommateur et
à travers le jeu d'ailleurs des hélices
avec ton de 30 centimes on peut espérer
gagner bidos quand même c'est quand même
formidable donc oui c'est vrai que
c'est ce qu'est ce qu'ils attendent
souvent c'est justement le tout l'aspect
spéculatif et la possibilité soit de
nouvel eldorado qui vont s'y faire
penser qu'on peut gagner beaucoup
d'argent avec avec avec feu
maïlys vous pensez qu à terme alors
encore une fois comme vous disiez que
vous n'êtes pas une spécialiste de 2 de
l'économie de l'abonné mais bon c'est
qu'à terme
les monnaies nationales ou sauce aux
sons vont laisser la place à ses cryptes
omnès où il y aura les deux marchés vos
fonds
alors la place peut-être pas entièrement
que je pense qu'aujourd'hui la monnaie
de confiance c'est notamment leur le
rocher noble et le dollar états unis
d'ailleurs il ya des crypto qui sont des
symboles coyne donc cessons de l'école
qui vont être stables et généralement
elles sont basées sur le dollar us donc
c'est pas pour rien qu'ils se fixent là
dessus c'est pour moi
après les banques réfléchissent beaucoup
à créer leur propre credo donc peut-être
qu'on aura surtout certaines crypto qui
vous monte avec lesquels on va pouvoir
échanger plus facilement et du coup
rendre la monnaie à un peu plus
volatiles entre euros le bitcoin des
terres
très bien et ben on va passer au
troisième terme le métavers
alors je crois que c'est plutôt
valérie damilleville un oui vous êtes
intéressés alors c'est vrai qu'alors on
a
on a découvert ce bout il ya quelques
temps mais c'est vrai que le changement
de facebook a accéléré cette
reconnaissance c'est quoi le métavers la
limite à garder comme comme les crypto
monnaie ou l'énergie tte ça existe déjà
depuis un certain temps c'est pas aussi
intéresse depuis quelques temps ah oui
mais ça va passer aussi
déjà ça existe dans l'hymne dans
l'imaginaire dans la fiction dans le jeu
dans le jeu et ça existe dans une
fiction quand on regarde de matrix par
exemple déjà les les créateurs de
fiction ont déjà se sont déjà intéressés
au sujet il ya déjà pas mal de temps et
ça existe dans le jeu depuis depuis
longtemps depuis depuis les jeux comme
minecraft par exemple comme secondlife
compte effectivement créer de
la nouveauté avec la réalité virtuelle
également la nouveauté avec les métavers
c'est que il ya une espèce de deux
passerelles une interaction entre le
virtuel et le réel donc fait des choses
dans le virtuel que vous pouvez
transformer le réel vous pouvez acheter
virtuellement une robe pour votre avatar
que vous pouvez éventuellement après
transformer en objet réel dans la vraie
vie adacore et donc c'est comme les
paires de chaussures
pour les avoir c'est pour ça que entre
autres facebook qui a changé de nom la
guigne de facebook s'appelle méthane
mais pas maintenant la holding de
facebook s'appelle matin et pour ses
équipes accompagnent au fait ça
probablement parce que parce que je fais
ce blog est un peu probablement puisque
son coeur berg a compris que la propri
qu'effectivement cette clé c'était une
mutation possible des réseaux sociaux et
puis puis parce qu'on sait tous que
facebook y a plein tourmente là depuis
depuis quelques années et que ça lui
permet d'occuper le terrain avec
d'autres sujets
ces sujets juridiques qu'il est qui qui
qui clash et donc c'est le jeu qui
appuya qui essaient massivement emparé
emparé de ça
et aujourd'hui il ya énormément là aussi
de de recherche par le jeu mais pas
uniquement le jeu sur sa défaire se
faisaient passer le niveau de jeu et
c'est pour ça que facebook s'y intéresse
on parle même de l'évolution possible
des réseaux sociaux sur
dans dans le métavers ce avec des
consommateurs et des marques qui joue
sur les deux tableaux sur le virtuel et
sur le réel et on essaye de
de voir comment est-ce qu'on peut
transformer des comportements virtuelle
dans la réalité ils commencent que cette
virtualité peut s'incarner dans la
réalité et comment effectivement on peut
s'habiller virtuellement en tant
qu'avatar dans une réalité virtuelle et
retrouver cette virtualité dans la
réalité on arrête d'accord c'est cette
série c'est ça ces deux mondes qui se
ravise un peu et donc c'est intéressant
au sens où on est à la fois ce qui est
un peu le cas déjà sur les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui on est à la fois
utilisateurs et producteurs de contenus
et le jeu c'est le cas de minecraft et
pedro blocks qui il a en ce moment
explose sur les sur les notamment les
adolescents où on est donc en
utilisateurs ont créé son nom créé son
avatar et on peut être également
développeur sent qu'on peut développer
ses propres personnages sur ce jeu par
exemple qui rend bloc se développe ses
propres personnages et on peut les
vendre aussi en utilisant la mode de la
monnaie virtuelle en opérant qui
s'appelait le robuste je pense et non
qu'on utilise une monnaie virtuelle qui
apprennent se transforme en monnaie
réelle et on crée ses propres
personnages on peut vendre ses propres
personnages à travers le jeu d'accord
donc le jeu est complètement lessivé
dire que nous alors on va être dans un
monde par exemple si je
dans virginie jeu très bien au tennis de
table justice
très bien aussi donc on prend un masque
ou tous les deux vous êtes à 200 km dont
jouent ensemble c'est là ça c'est celle
ci c'est possible ça se fait dit ça
c'est le jeu
maintenant si
vous écrivez le livre avec avec maelys
pourrait rester aussi à 500 km et faire
comme si vous étiez la même table un
double 6 à 1 c'est un petit changement
donc donc on voit un peu l'un dont on
peut voir l'intérêt pour les entreprises
en effet dans le travail voilà on y est
beaucoup le télétravail qui a pris le
bébé ça peut ça peut servir la sueur des
sur des sujets comme ça non mais tout à
fait notamment visioconférence ou bien
je sais que beaucoup d'entreprises
travail sur la conception d'hologrammes
qui permettront en fait de mettre
d'abord une image telle qu'elle est
c'est comme si on est là alors qu'on est
à 500 kilomètres les uns des autres
donc ça se voit c'est bien
d'intérêt après il ya par exemple un des
lanceurs d'alert
qui ont qui ont été prévenir les députés
français ont leur disons love fait très
attention à ce qui est en train de faire
gerber et facebook c'est très dangereux
cette doublure numérique du monde
physique où l'entreprise entrevoit
d'immenses possibilités commerciales
quelques possibilités commerciales on
voit à peu près ce qui veut dire
dès lors de trimeris a réuni des données
qu'elles sont utilisées que finalement
il ya un monde virtuel qui se dessine ça
veut dire que là où on est déjà ça fait
des années qu'on en parle de tout ce qui
agrège
facebook là ce sera encore plus fort et
encore à des fins commerciales va
recueillir des données aussi encore plus
forte sur le sur les gens qui sur les
individus signer ce qu'on appelle la
data en marketing donc on va affiner la
la donner et on va la rendre tellement
précises
on pourra la monétiser et la monétiser
de plus en plus et il à rendre et lui
donner une valeur nous avons des valeurs
marchandes une très forte l'abonné
personnel aujourd'hui et et c'est ce qui
fait la puissance us et des dégâts
fameux gaf 1 c'est la donnée personnelle
et donc là on va la rendre encore plus
ce sera encore plus intrusif en plus
parallèlement on crée un ont créé un
environnement un écosystème qui va nous
rendre un peu dépendant un peu parce que
parce que la guerre fin faut pas se
leurrer elle est là elle est si j'occupe
enfin si je suis sur facebook su pendant
ce temps-là bailleurs et j'ai l'idée
c'est d'être de s'ancrer dans le
quotidien de l'utilisateur parce que
pour avoir des réflexes est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui cette étude qui montre
que la première chose que font les
français c'est se lever regarder
facebook avant dire bonjour à sa femme
ou son mari donc on se dit qu'à partir
au moment où l'habitude étant créée elle
est difficilement comme il ya déjà un
peu voilà rétorque le christ d'aller
encore toulouse voilà d'aller encore
plus loin pour s'intégrer pour faire en
sorte qu'ils aient vraiment tout un
environnement et qu'on s'en détache pas
mais qu'on voit des gazaouis donc dans
les restaurants cafés des gens qui
téléphonent qu'ils sont ensemble et puis
qui ne regardent leur téléphone plutôt
de parler à la personne qui est en face
ont des jobs dans ce monde là et puis
c'est un monde on en parlait avec les
crypto mode et total ou la nef tai chi
ceux qui se
l'ibère du physique au fond
c'est ça aussi le talent on peut créer
le physical physique ne comptent plus
quoi on peut faire venir donc notamment
sur ce fameux jeu eurobloc ce qu'on veut
faire rentrer du virtuel mais à partir
le physique c'est pour ça que des
concerts qui sont qui sont virtuellement
organisé mais parler par les artistes
eux-mêmes donc il ya ce grand rappeur
exquis à qui a intégré justement
fortnight le fait aussi faire tout tout
tout l'univers des jeux vidéo une surf
justement sur 7 sur cette double
double attirance qui crée des
passerelles entre entre le virtuel et le
réel et ont rejoint une chose c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure finalement
le parcours utilisateur l'expérience
utilisateur prend le dessus sur le
produit puisque là il ya pas de produits
fins et tout est virtuel c'est
l'expérience qui compte c'est de vivre
et donc là c'est ce qui est intéressant
aussi pour les nouveaux utilisateurs
c'est qu'ils sont complètement créateurs
ou co créé un co créateurs de contenu
sauf que à terme potentiellement c'est
eux qui pourront créer des collections
entières de chaussures de vêtements de
deux voitures pourquoi pas avec quelques
et marque donc les marques qu'ils voient
et une dimension mercantile mais aussi
une dimension peut-être créative de deux
nouvelles relations si on voit l'aspv
reculer chose il ya effectivement
l'aspect dangereux qu'est keller mais il
peut y avoir un aspect vertueux on peut
imaginer que les parcs entre
entretiennent une nouvelle relation plus
constructive plus créatives peut-être
avec leur avec l'utilisateur ben
justement vous avez vous abordé la
partie basse est vraiment une conclusion
puisqu'il nous reste quatre minutes à
peine mondou virtuel mode réel est ce
que tout ça est v nous annonce une
société plutôt meilleure ou plutôt plus
compliqué c'est la question que vous
posez
[Musique]
alors justement week ce monde qu'on peut
imaginer beaucoup plus virtuel qu'il
n'est aujourd'hui bien que comme vous le
disiez ça commence déjà il vous inquiète
tous excite plus tôt moi c'est une
nature optimiste je dirais que je trouve
que c'est une formidable opportunité
à plein de niveaux en fait je pense que
dans la consommation mais ça décloisonne
les zones de chalandise pour les
entreprises aussi sinon on était sur une
donne était très locale aujourd'hui on
peut s'ouvrir au monde entier que chez
soi c'est aussi pour les gens de pouvoir
travailler du monde entier cette façon
et nomad digital nomades on peut
travailler avoir un métier s'ils se
former à des métiers nouveaux qui leur
étaient avant qui était pas accessible
moi je trouve que évidemment il ya des
risques comme tout évidemment il ya des
limites évidemment il faut les connaître
mais mais derrière ça je trouve que
c'est incroyable ce qu'on vit est
incroyable et à chaque fois elle se dit
on entend parfois des gens qui vont dire
mais tout est fait il ya plus rien à
faire mais non on est toujours bien
s'agir là toujours surpris et peut-être
pour la première fois la vendée on est
face à un monde aux tons
on a du mal même à imaginer comment ils
comment il va être assez c'est assez
fascinant vous
vous étudiants d'ailleurs c'est pas ils
sont là à parler après mais the ivory
vont inventer un monde nouveau oui ils
sont ils sont déjà très précurseur ils
sont déjà très en avance sur
tout un tas de sujets
je squatte monde d'accord avec ce que
dit et bien fini je reviens sur ce qu'on
disait un peu au début de l'émission
soit l'éthique je pense qu'il faut quand
même ça c'est important je pense qu'il
est très important pour l'utilisateur
mais comme les marches pense que les
marques ont vraiment appuyé pouvoirs
publics aussi éducation nous
il est très important qu'on qu'on ne se
laisse pas embarquer effectivement part
du tout techno toute innovation qui est
formidable parce que je sens que c'est
vraiment extraordinaire ou détriment
d'un certain nombre de valeurs et
d'éthique aussi penser c'est vrai qu'on
n'en avait pas parlé des heures mais sur
les cryptes monnaie tout ce qui est
consommation derrière donc c'est vrai
que derrière c'est
la
rdc comme des limites il faut quand même
les maisons les prendre en compte mais
mais on peut pas on peut pas stopper
l'avancé donc il faut il faut travailler
avec et faut justement faire en sorte de
l'améliorer et c'est là où il y aura des
belles innovations c'est après en chaque
fois amélioré tous ces points de nick et
moi je crois beaucoup justement à cette
capacité de co-création entendre entre
les marques les pouvoirs publics eux les
profs les formateurs
les médias occidentaux plutôt voyons
plutôt optimiste optimus très bientôt
petits messieurs merci merci infiniment
merci david habib merci beaucoup monde à
calixte je rappelle donc se hâter
représentants de mike digital school
donc il y en a une à lui réduit en vous
continuez votre route et le bretonneux
tout à la main et puis des écoles
partout partout en france
virginie fév et merci infiniment on
rappelle startac donc formation en
entreprise et pour en intérêts en intra
donc sur deux formules et on servier en
france entière pour les entreprises et
maylis bulk merci infiniment de tous ces
éclairages sur les gènes fp et les
crypto beau des ivg rappelle que vous
êtes la côte ris avec avec virginie de
stratégie et hip marketing merci à tous
et à très vite pour du nouveau numéro de
poste j'espère qu'on aura l'occasion de
se revoir parce que tout ça est
passionnant comme m merci
[Musique]